- I feel like I have big teeth.
- You have perfect size teeth.
- I think I have big teeth.
Like Chiclets.
- And look at them.
And look how sparkly
and white and perfect.
- I have the little Madonna gap too.
- It's perfect.
- That's what I call it,
the Madonna gap.
'Cause I feel cooler 'cause she has one.
- Really?
- Yeah.
I don't know if she wants
it to be called that.
- I like that game.
- Wait.
I want to talk about your show.
- Let's talk about the show.
- Let's talk about your show
'cause your show is awesome.
It's such a cool idea.
The World According to Jeff Goldblum.
And tell everybody what the
kind of premise of it is.
- Well it's on Disney Plus.
They just by the way renewed
us for a second season.
- Nice.
(clapping)
- It's the first time I'm
mentioning it publicly.
- Oh yeah.
- I found out today.
- That's so exciting.
We're gonna do a bunch
more this next year.
I had a great time shooting them.
They are me following
familiar objects like flowers.
- Or coffee?
- Or coffee we did.
We did sneakers.
Barbecues.
RVs.
Cosmetics.
Jewelry.
Different things.
- Just every day things kinda.
- Every day things.
But we find the interesting,
complicated, surprising
things about them.
And then I move in and
out of the aficionados
on the subject and have an experience.
May give way to my personal associations
and a personal epiphany
or revelation of some kind
and also some facts about
it that may be interesting
and some abstractions and larger ideas.
What do you think of that?
- That was a lot.
That was a lot.
So wait, what is something
that's kind of amazed you?
- Well there've been amazing things.
In that clip you saw us go to Texas,
we were in Houston at Johnny
Dang's Grill Emporium.
- Sounds about right.
- They gave me a grill.
They made a grill for me.
I have a grill that I didn't wear today,
but I have a grill.
(laughing)
- Did you post a picture of it?
- Yeah, I think there's
been a picture of it.
- Oh my.